virginia
new jersey
new york minneapolis
seattle texas
today is a wake-up call for washington
democrats
the same big government socialists who
were rejected in states like virginia
are doubling down on their their failed
policies even after their losses nancy
pelosi doubled down on her agenda yet
again this morning and that is exactly
why she is a lame duck speaker of the
house
republicans react let's talk about all
of this with the man in the middle of
the tax and spending debate and all the
legislation here west virginia
democratic senator joe manchin senator
thanks for joining us good to be with
you how did you see that election you
hear how republicans see it how did you
see it i just saw it to confirm that we
have a divided country when you think of
two blue states or one state virginia
has been leaning blue and been fairly
blue for 10 years
georgia georgia's always been
historically blue
and to see what had happened and how
close and how divided can you imagine
2.2 million votes in new jersey and 100
or 200 votes separation how close it was
in virginia um i think i hope it's a
wake-up call for all of us we need to do
that let's take it from it do you think
what should they take from well i would
think that you know let's say on the
legislation
we're about to to start negotiating on
which is the reconciliation bill there's
no excuse why the infrastructure bill
hasn't passed
long ago two weeks three weeks ago it
had been great for our country it's
still great for our country and i'm
hoping we get bipartisan support it's a
bipartisan bill but reconciliation but i
think what it says is kind of slow down
take a breath let's look at this we're
talking about major tax overhaul reform
we're talking about changing our energy
policies we're talking about a whole
social rearrangement
we're talking about 29 trillion dollars
of debt we better get our hands around
it and and be responsible and i've
always said if you can't get your
financial house in order it's hard to do
anything you know president biden was
asked today about what he thought the
issue was in virginia take a listen to
this answer
do you think that terry mcauliffe would
have won if your agenda had passed
before election day well uh
i think we should have should have
passed before election day
but i'm not sure that i would be able to
have changed the
number of very conservative folks who
turned out in
the red districts who were trump voters
but maybe
you think if infrastructure had passed
before election day
on its own merits it's a piece of bill
that we've worked about months ago took
five months to put together they've had
in the house for two months we've been
begging them
you know but they keep wanting to link
them and there's no such thing as
linking two pieces of legislation or
holding one hostage over the other they
should go up and down on their own
merits they should be worked on their
own merits well to that point economy
was really a major issue in this
election the top issue so this passage
of infrastructure and reconciliation
those two bills
help or hurt
that message
well if you don't take in consideration
what people are going through at the gas
pumps and at the grocery stores the
inflation that's coming at first we
thought it was transitory if you recall
brett about a month or more ago i said
let's take a strategic pause let's see
where we are we don't know about cove
but it kept the variance of covert kept
going up and down we weren't sure what
is going to have effect on our economy
they kept saying well this inflation
area
thing is basically maybe transitory and
we're finding out it's not and then we
have a geopolitical fallout from
afghanistan that we're going to have to
deal with sooner or later somewhere in
the world and i said the need that we
have right now of all the aspirational
things in the reconciliation bill
most of that is covered in the arp bill
with the american rescue plant that we
voted in january 1.9 trillion we have
people cover clear up through 2022 and
beyond so it wasn't like an urgent and i
don't know why we're acting like it's so
urgent so does this result last night
embolden you to make sure that the build
back better or the reconciliation bill
does no harm to the economy oh
absolutely i'm concerned about no oh
absolutely i'm concerned i've been
talking about our debt i've been talking
about inflation i've been talking about
the fallout we may have and all these
things and you know maybe they've
listened and maybe they have and we'll
see we'll see if they don't all right so
on the gas prices gas prices at the pump
who's to blame president biden says opec
is to blame others say climate policies
have changed the dynamic what do you say
i say that we can basically do more for
ourselves we've been energy independent
for the first time in 67 years why can't
we do more why can't we produce more
we've got plenty of natural gas my state
beautiful state of west virginia has an
ocean of natural gas under it if they
just let us build a pipeline we can get
the product to market and why don't we
do more drilling and why don't we do
more basically production in the united
states i'm not depending on opec i'm not
depending on other countries for my
energy anymore we know how to do it we
have the technology we should be relying
on ourselves is the president wrong in
that i have a difference of opinion
so yes
i want to talk about process because the
house is moving forward with both of
these bills and we've got reporting from
chad program a group of five moderate
democrats insisting that the bill the
buildback better bill get a full cbo
congressional budget office score before
it goes to the floor potentially as
early as tomorrow as a result democratic
leaders are trying to force the issue
pressure these moderate democrats to
vote yes moderate democrats were told
are irate that they are having to fillet
2135 pages of new legislation on the fly
quote re-resent it said one moderate
democratic source this is only
strengthening our resolve what do you
say to those moderate i would say to all
of my house friends on both the democrat
and republican side but speaking to my
democrat sides there has to build some
build some good will
let them vote on the infrastructure bill
take the time to work the reconciliation
bill the way it needs to be worked the
cbo's scoring talking more about the
effects it has all through our economy
and all through people's lives that's
something reasonable to ask i understand
that and i'm not going to tell anyone
how they should run their end of this
congress of ours and nancy pelosi is
very capable i know her she's i get
along fine with her we just you know
maybe come from two different parts of
the country and two different
philosophical beliefs
in that bill that's going to be filed
either tonight or tomorrow uh there are
taxes there's language to raise taxes on
individuals below the 400 000 threshold
and
one of them is on nicotine have you
changed your position or on regressive
taxes or anything below that four
hundred thousand well i never thought
the four hundred thousand bears should
have been there began okay if you're
going to do tax reform do tax reform uh
the last time we had a balanced budget
with with surpluses was when everybody
paid a little bit of something making
sure that the richest of the richest and
all of those are in between
but with that where we are right now uh
attacks on nicotine
that doesn't make any sense to me
whatsoever is that a non-starter for you
well there's so many things in there i
guess you have a lot of nonsense i have
a lot of concerns let's put it that way
but i'm not going to they're working off
the house bill that's not going to be
the bill i work off of
so
somebody's sitting at home on the couch
and they're listening to this and we
explain the process but sometimes you
need a whiteboard because there's a lot
of stuff happening over here
when
would this process move forward in your
mind this process if they're going to
vote on it tomorrow then it'll go
through the scrub of next week
then it'll be a week before it comes to
us as i understand
so if that comes over and they start
working off of that
and then we have a reconciliation
program with a voter rama that basically
has a bird rule and these are all pretty
technical things but it basically sees
as it fits if it doesn't fit once we get
a ruling from the parliamentarian forget
about this people might be all excited
about something now or say that's a
non-starter it might not even fit in the
bill because on our side it doesn't fit
it doesn't come within the rules of
reconciliation so wait until that's done
see what you have before you and then we
start voting so for example speaker
pelosi wants to put paid leave policies
on small businesses in a partisan patent
i'm more concerned about unpaid leave
because if you put that paid leave in
it's not being paid for i'm all for paid
leave and i believe that people should
have but you think it should be done
separately separately completely
separately because we can do this in a
bipartisan way brett anything that we do
in a bipartisan way is lasting it stays
and this is something where both the
employer employees can participate
people can build up their credits and
use their time as they desire what about
anything that deals with immigration
legal status now i understand you're
talking about what the parliamentarian's
going to rule but senator menendez said
listen we're going to take no
no doesn't work for us we're going to
plow forward on this thing i'm not going
to vote to overrule the parliamentarian
i've always said they call that the bird
rule yeah and that's when you go outside
robert byrd from west virginia
the seat i said in right now and i'm not
going to do that they all know that
if the parliamentary rules on something
if if if the people that have been here
working
are allowed to continue to work and help
our economy and and help their family
but help all of us we all benefit from
it
i'm not for basically let's just take
the parliamentarian out of it and say
you do you support some kind of amnesty
without border security and the
reconciliation for us to even be talking
about immigration without border
security is ludicrous i've told him i
said people the average person turns on
on the tv and sees what's going on in
the border
and that basically scares the bejesus
out of an awful lot of people if they
think they can come and get all the
different benefits that people that
citizens of america can get are entitled
to they're going to continue to come
so no i don't think so border security
in 2013 the bill that we did
we try to have a pathway to citizenship
we take care of our dreamers which i
have a lot of compassion for and i would
love to do something for people that
came even if they came wrong pay your
fine get in line 10 years back you won't
be jumping lying but nobody becomes a
citizen until the border is declared
secured so that's not happening i know
it's not and that's what's up that's
what you're saying that was that
republican and democrat and democrats in
2013 bret that passed what i thought the
best piece of legislation that we
couldn't get a vote on in the house two
more questions one is you've had people
out to your house boat you've had people
following you around you've had
progressives you know
protesting you corey bush says
joe manchin's opposition to build back
better act is anti-black anti-child
anti-woman anti-immigrant when we talk
about transformative change we are
talking about a bill that will benefit
black brown and indigenous communities
your response to congresswoman i would
just say the congresswoman doesn't know
me
she doesn't know me
and
happy to talk to her i think maybe
she'll have a different opinion go home
to west virginia and ask people i think
you'll get a different opinion and this
is a shame when we start this war a war
of words i'm not going to speak you all
about any of my congressional
friends and and colleagues on the house
side or the senate side we can have a
difference of opinion
the rhetoric around here has gotten so
harsh and so toxic that you can't agree
to disagree anymore you can't sit down
and say okay i disagree with you brett
you're gonna say okay joe do we agree on
the same problem i said yeah let's start
working tell me what you think you would
fix it that's not happening so
congratulations let me tell you what i
don't hear what scares the jesus out of
me
i don't hear people saying this is good
for our country
it's more or less on both sides this is
better for my party this is better for
the 2022 let me end where i started last
night's election okay the congressional
progressive
caucus in the house now stands at 95
members looking at last night and the
results of it
what's the over under for 2022 well are
there more or the progressives the
progressives and i spoke to some of them
and they're nice people good people
they're aspirational i don't believe
philosophically with them at all
but they don't have any chance of
getting defeated where they come from
the thing they're doing is basically
changing the dynamics of the moderates
that it takes for them to be in a
majority
taking it down
way low i've asked you this seven times
but has your party left you
i'm a west virginia democrat brad i
don't know i don't know where maybe i
belong at times but i believe i'm
fiscally responsible
and socially compassionate and you know
what i have a lot of democrats that feel
the same as i do i have all the
republicans feel the same as i do
senator as always thank you thank you
brett appreciate it god bless america
appreciate thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else